I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense we're very careful about what we
put into our mind because we know that
that's what's going to manifest into our
reality right I I believe you know most
people aren't truly conscious of that
when we became conscious of that it
changed everything
yeah again back to working out back to
eating whatever you put in your body
yeah that's whatever you feed yourself
that's what's going to eventually
manifest in the physical yeah well why
wouldn't it be the same thing whatever
you put into your mind is what's going
to come out and see out of your words
and out of your perception so we're
mindful of it whatever we're watching
whatever we were listening to whoever
we're associating with we want to make
sure that it aligns with whatever we
believe and what we want in our life you
know we kind of put it through a filter
does this align with our value system
and does this get us closer to our goal
if it doesn't match those two things
then why are we doing it mm-hmm
right so yeah so we're conscious about
what we put in and you know we make sure
that we we stay healthy you know we keep
our mind right associations a really
really big thing as well and who we're
aligning herself with we always try to
get us ourselves around people that
stretch us mm-hmm you know that grow us
job that workout again used to be a
trainer so I think this morning
man will flash back to it's a pre pre
Frances yeah but no you're pretty
intense by danika everyone is really
intense
but we love it but we aren't we're
always getting ourselves around people
that that stretch us yeah you know
they're gonna if you a goldfish is only
gonna grow to the size of the pond that
it's in so is that true if you put them
in a bigger tank they would get bigger
yeah yeah so it as human beings in our
evolution process and our expansion
process it's only natural if you're
gonna hang around with the same crowd
well then you can take the some of those
results and tell yourself you can figure
out what you're gonna be you know
projected 10 to 15 20 years down there
just say something like show me your
five friends and I'll show you
yeah yeah so if you want a different
result in your life you know you're
gonna have to put yourself around people
that are gonna consistently sharpen the
iron grow and stretch you to become a
better human you know and it's
uncomfortable and it's not easy and just
like the workout this morning was not
easy but uh but it ultimately makes you
better and you're you're you're more
grateful for the for the final result so
yeah daily rituals are key
you know meditation take I mean people
do all kinds of things take cold showers
in the morning whatever you have to do
to get yourself primed and ready for the
day so that because you're gonna
typically wake up in a negative state
the brain naturally it it is always
usually typically gonna gravitate
towards the negative because that's
protection mm-hmm it's kind of always
probably gonna look for what's wrong hmm
you know as you walk into a new
situation you're gonna survey the room
and you know it's a safe and you're
gonna look for maybe what's wrong in the
environment naturally if you're not
really in control of your thoughts just
so that oh is that a natural thing or is
that a learned thing like do we like
based on growing up do we just kind of
get trained to go make sure it's safe
like watch before you cross the road is
this a train thing or a train I think
some of it can be yeah I think a hundred
thousand years ago yeah probably just
survival you have running from the Lions
in the open field I don't know crazy
stuff yeah fortunately were dinosaurs
real you know fortunately we're not
having to deal with those kinds of those
kinds of threats in our life but our
body is wired to completely look for
sure things and to protect and preserve
right so when you wake up and your
stream of consciousness is going for
most people they wake up in a negative
state yeah you know they're the fears of
the day the insecurities the doubts the
what could go wrong and so you have to
grab hold of your thoughts take them
captive and and get yourself in a prime
state to speak differently and look
differently I've been waking up I saw
something that someone did they said
just wake up and say thank you
and so I wake up and literally say that
one word which I could totally manage
that as a practice my 10 minute made us
tation falls by the wayside most of the
time but I can wake up and say thank you
and it's amazing the difference in your
like vibration yeah and trajectory then
like it's almost like you set the set
like you throw a dart in the morning and
you as soon as you let it go saying
thank you it's going forward it's going
towards positive yeah no absolutely
you